something fun maybe your music program
yeah like music
[Applause]
[Music]
maybe we can have amazing after school
programs cardi B is giving back it's a
blessing for God on Tuesday the rapper
gave the students and staff at her
former Middle School in the Bronx a
super-sized surprised when she stopped
by with a big cash donation
yeah cardi showed up dressed to impress
in an all red number
and broke down what her donation means
for the kids
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
then cardi hit them with the amount I
don't know I don't know I don't know but
I will be donating a hundred thousand
dollars
you heard right the Grammy winner is
donating a hundred K oh yes honey cardi
shared the moment on Instagram
explaining just how much it meant to her
in the caption saying the school has a
very special place in my heart it turned
me from an 11 year old girl into a
little teenage adult she adds like many
of those kids she went through a lot
during her time there I hope my donation
can help create an amazing after school
program that will help kids stay out the
streets or a troubled home and most
importantly allow them to learn
something that they can take with them
through life people don't understand
some people don't understand the the
struggle some people don't understand
the work that I put in so they will just
always try to think that it came easy
for me and it's just like you know it's
something that I never thought it would
be and there are seemingly more
surprises on the way cardi also teases
she's been working on a secret project
for two years that's also close to her
heart so while we wait to see what that
is we'll soak up this sweet Moment One
More Time
eating a hundred thousand dollars
[Music]